these marine biologists are hunting for
an almost mythical creature it has the
head of a horse the tail of a serpent
and an insect like armor of bony plates
but it's really a fish the niceness even
though it's a little male spread smoke
gets frequent it's interesting because a
lot of people think seahorses Monika
Fiorito not many people actually when do
you see Melissa's exist there are only
about 35 species of seahorses and
biologists fear for their survival
these fish are extremely fragile they
only eat live brine shrimp and are
sensitive to small changes in their
habitats pollution boats and fluctuating
water temperatures can easily destroy
whole colonies
that's why marine biologists have come
here to South Africa to study one of the
rarest seahorses the NIH's now they have
no idea how many niceness seahorses
there are but they exist nowhere else on
earth
mark NAAFI is part of a team of
volunteer divers trying to mathematica
seahorse habitats the CIO's is an
endangered species was not not because
of the numbers because we didn't
actually know before this project how
many they were but because they only
occurred in these two histories while
natural dissolves you can work the
matter
County and seahorses isn't easy the
water often eyes now is under 14 degrees
Celsius and visibility close to zero
the divers follow a slender line that
delineates the search area then comb
through a thick carpet of seaweed sea
horses like chameleons change color to
hide the male's wrap their slender tails
around the green stalks and sway like
the weeds
the divers carefully measure each little
seahorse and record observations and no
clothes the Fisher replaced where
they're found to minimize any disruption
in their feeding and mating habits hares
mate for life
the female providing the eggs to the
male who fertilizes them in his pouch
and carries the young and till they pass
I guess the the unique reproductive
strategy that that they have with the
the male falling pregnant and giving
birth to the young I mean that's very
unusual there's not many animal species
not many fish species that have that
reversal in sex roles once the
biologists know more about these fragile
seahorses they hope to come up with
better ways to protect them